We have to talk about the Afghanistan papers.
Okay. There is a Washington post report which
I will read a little bit from to get us acclimated.
The Afghanistan papers are a confidential
trove of government documents obtained by
the Washington post revealing that senior
U S officials failed to tell the truth about
the war in Afghanistan throughout the 18 year
campaign making rosy pronouncements. They
knew to be false and hiding unmistakable evidence
that the war had become unwinnable more than
2000 pages of previously unpublished notes
of interviews with people who played a direct
role in the war from generals and diplomats
and aid workers and Afghan officials have
been published.
The quotes are damning. The what these Afghanistan
papers effectively are telling us is that
not only has it been a corrupt disaster, but
that a lot of people involved knew that it
was a corrupt, poorly planned disaster for
a very long time and still the money flow
continued and the public pronouncements that
this was the right war. Remember Iraq? Okay.
Iraq was the wrong war. Afghanistan was the
right war. 18 years. It was a disaster. All
right, quote from Douglas lute. Douglas lute
is a three-star army general who was the white
house's Afghan Wars are during both the Bush
and Obama, Obama administrations in 2015 he
said, we were devoid of a fundamental understanding
of Afghanistan. We didn't know what we were
doing. What are we trying to do here? We didn't
have the foggiest notion of what we were undertaking.
Remember publicly, we were told Iraq went
sideways.
Maybe we went in for the wrong reason, but
we're doing the right thing in Afghanistan.
Um, loot also said if the American people
knew the magnitude of the disfunction, 2,400
lives lost. Who will say that this was in
vain? There has been a PR management of the
Afghanistan war to portray it as properly
run successful reflecting an understanding
of the region which we lacked in Iraq and
it was all a farce. The Washington post goes
on to say that since 2001 more than 775,000
us troops have deployed to Afghanistan, many
repeatedly of those 2300 died there. Nearly
21,000 were wounded in action. While with
most speaking on the assumption that their
remarks would not become public, us officials
acknowledged this is from the Afghanistan
papers, that their war fighting strategies
were fatally flawed and that Washington wasted
enormous sums of money trying to remake Afghanistan
into a modern nation.
This is not just about money. It has been
an incredible, uh, a quagmire when it comes
to money, but it has been a foreign policy
disaster as well. Uh, the Washington post,
uh, the interviews also highlight the U S
government's botched attempts to curtail runaway
corruption, build a competent Afghan army
and police force. I remember we were told
we're doing really good work. We're building
up their army and their police force into
one that works well. And to put a dent in
Afghanistan is thriving opium trade. The U
S government has not carried out a comprehensive
accounting of how much it is even spent on
the war in Afghanistan. But the costs are
staggering. Listen to these numbers. Since
2001 the defense department, state department,
and us agency for international development
have spent or appropriated between 934,000,000,970
8 billion. We're talking about almost a trillion
dollars. Jeffrey Eggers, who's a retired Navy
seal and white house staffer for Bush and
Obama again said to government interviewers,
we now know that he said this because the
Afghanistan papers have gone public quote,
what did we get for this $1 trillion effort?
Was it worth $1 trillion after the killing
of Osama bin Laden? I said that Osama was
probably laughing in his watery grave considering
how much we have spent on Afghanistan. The
Afghanistan papers. Describe what the Washington
post calls constant deception quote. Every
data point was altered to represent the best
picture possible. This is, according to Bob
Crowley, an army Colonel who was senior counter-insurgency
advisor surveys, for instance, were totally
unreliable, but reinforced that everything
we was doing we were doing was right and we
became a self-licking ice cream cone. This
is a scandal, okay? This doesn't diminish
any of Donald Trump's scandals. This says
nothing about the impeachment. This is a scandal.
It is the type of scandal that does not get
a lot of attention. I remember the Panama
papers, it got a little attention, but then
these things tend to fade. These documents,
these interview transcripts should be front
page news for a very long time.
The framing was Iraq didn't go so well, but
Afghanistan is moral. It's successful. We're
doing the right thing. It's not corrupt. We
know where the money's going. We know everything
that's going on and now we find out from,
from people who were on the ground there,
we had no understanding of what was going
on. We had no understanding of what we were
doing. The accounting is a farce. Claims were
routinely made publicly that things were going
well. When it's not just that it was an exaggeration,
people knew that it was an absolute and total
disaster. This is the exposure of an embarrassing
multi-decade fiasco that is just barely a
blip on the radar and it's not. I know it's
easy to say, well, damn David, if everybody
stopped focusing less on Trump, then we would
hear more about this. I don't buy that. This
is not the type of story that tends to get
a lot of attention.
Years ago there were claims made. We had Abu
Ghraib, right? That was the Iraqi prison where
there was horrible, horrible, a wrongdoing
by a American members of the military. There
were supplementary documents and reports about
truly horrible things that were taking place
there and at other facilities it may barely
made a blip on the radar. There was no impeachment
scandal at the time. There was no, you know,
we didn't have a president tweeting 20 to
a hundred times a day at the time and it still
did not get nearly the attention that it deserves.
These stories don't do well because corporate
media sets the narrative. People died because
of bureaucratic issues. $1 trillion is gone.
We have no clue what's going on there and
to the extent that I'm able to, I will continue
talking about this story because it is so
important and it is so, so incredible.
Check out the documents yourselves, widely
available online, Washington post again as
a very, very good report and summary about
it.